all right look man you got the floor
what the hell is going on
dude dude i don't know man this is uh so
i'll start by saying joe that was a
phenomenal speech man i appreciate you
on everything that i've been talking
about in my career for the past 13 years
i've been saying this you guys know me
you know i grew up very poor you know
i've been on wall street for uh a really
long time or technically off wall street
rather but um you know a lot of what
we're talking about is we was sort of we
saw the seeds of this discussion going
back to the fed's response to the
financial crisis and their financial
response to every single sort of equity
market pullback we've seen since the
financial crisis and then you layer on
the fiscal policy response that in our
opinion was a function of the zeitgeist
against the the
incessant uh monetary easing uh at every
equity market stifle that we've had
really throughout my career and this is
what you get you get food inflation it's
up at uh at a 40-year high 40 plus year
high you get shelter inflation it's at a
30-year high you get utilities inflation
to how much it costs to turn a light on
and i'll tell you i've been evicted
seven times in my life i've probably
spent the cumulative year of my lifetime
of my childhood doing homework in the
dark because we couldn't afford to keep
the lights on and that inflation
statistic is at an all-time high
and what do we get out of it we got a
stock market
when you think darius about what's going
on right now
how do you underwrite what the actual
inflation number is right seven and a
half percent i think everyone here
agrees is really really bad
but i actually don't think it is
highlighting how bad of the scenario it
is and there's two components one is is
the official number actually accurate
and then two is everyone in an economy
obviously doesn't experience the same
level of inflation like how do you think
about like how bad is it for the most
vulnerable people in society
uh it's terrible um so i'll tell you
there's two things one when you look at
cpi statistics you know the the bls is
making a tremendous amount of
assumptions on what goes into the basket
what comes out of the basket for
instance uh they made some revisions um
in this month's data to sort of more
accurately account for the shift to
consumption patterns throughout the
pandemic so there's a little bit more
weight on goods inflation uh relative to
services inflation but number two um
obviously you know when you look at it
in parson and and i would say the bls
actually does this on a bi-annual basis
in terms of um
uh surveying consumers and their
expenditures and how much different sort
of uh uh sort of quantiles of consumers
with respect to their income or their
wealth distribution how much they spend
on certain goods and services and the
last time i checked that i was a few
years ago but the reality is the lower
you go down the income spectrum the
greater and greater the shares of things
like you know rent uh for your energy
medical costs and those things take up
of your consumption your consumption is
very much not discretionary if anything
on the last time i checked it was pretty
much consumers are operating at around a
negative a net negative margin when you
factor in everything that they probably
have to spend money on and so you need
wage growth obviously to perpetuate any
sort of growth in that uh cohort
when you start to think about various
parts of uh of the metrics like things
like gasoline is up 40
how much of that is like monetary fiscal
policy and the lack of discipline there
and some of the past actions over the
last you know 24 months versus supply
chain and is it possible to break out
like the monetary policy impact versus
uh whether it's supply chain pipeline
you know regulation whatever else is
going on there
you could parse it out but there's no
point to right like you know when we
talk about supply chain disruptions we
have to remember supply chain
interruptions is not just supply it's
demand as well you can't have a supply
demand and balance without factoring in
demand and obviously as a function of
the record monetary and fiscal policy
that we received throughout the pandemic
um you know biggest fiscal programs ever
i think we did about 25 of gdp and
fiscal stimulus obviously the fed's
balance sheet doubled those two dynamics
really contributed to an excess uh
amount of demand relative to a decline
the declining or or significantly
reduced productive capacity of the
global economy and so that's what you
have is a sort of overstimulated demand
and under-stimulated um sort of supply
uh dynamic that created a lot of this
inflation so in my opinion you can try
to parse it out and i think it's
important to parse out as an investor
because that allows you some more
visibility on which avenues to further
express these types of bets but the
reality is as a human being as a
consumer who gives a [ __ ] you know and
part of my language right like
highest all-time you know highest food
prices you're spending since 1981
you know there's not a family in america
that gives a [ __ ] right you know i'm
sorry and again sorry part of my
language but i'm i'm very frustrated by
this because i i i felt this for many
many years of my life and i understand
what people are going through and
they're struggling right now and they're
probably asking folks for questions and
they're tuning into shows like yours and
thank you for providing uh leadership
here because the reality is there's not
enough leadership on wall street for
what is a god damn disaster
what is your take on uh interest rate
hikes kind of moving forward obviously
uh you know we see people like you know
jb diamond jp morgan saying there's
gonna be six seven different rate hikes
uh there's
various metrics in the market that are
showing you know pricing in of people
thinking 50 basis points in march uh a
full percentage point like what's your
take on how many and how severe uh and
at this point can they ignore it anymore
like do they have to hike interest rates
after a cpi print like this
well let me start by saying uh the funny
joke in the room right now is that
they're still buying bonds
the fed is still doing qe right now
i mean it's obviously not funny it's a
disaster but uh so yeah you made a great
point earlier right about um
you know
once the rich people start losing money
then they'll phone up the fed to fun of
the treasury and say hey look guys
you're this inflation's a problem now at
first right like we have record
corporate um operating margins here in
the us if you look at the s p 500
constituents and part of the reason we
have racket corporate operating margins
is because all this inflation that us
consumers and businesses are eating is
going straight to the bottom line of
these major corporations who are
obviously in bed with wall street who
are obviously the further in bed with
with the folks down in dc so you know
there's they're laughing to the bank and
this is why you've seen a record
earnings bonanza that's why you see
again record operating margins but there
comes to be a point where it becomes a
political problem right um at some point
it's a political problem for the people
who run the banks the people who run
these companies when their workers are
showing up saying hey look i'm out of
here if you don't pay me xyz and once
that all that starts to happen in mass
and we're obviously seeing that in the
most recent jobs report on
last friday we got the average hourly
earnings statistic jumped up to nine
percent on the season adjusted
annualized uh rate of change basis
that's the number fastest number we've
seen since um since the in a year but
the employment cost index which measures
everything that you have to pay your
employees to to get them to sit in a
seat and make you richer that number
ticked up to the fastest growth rate
we've seen in 20 years um going back a
couple weeks ago so you know the reality
is it's now starting to become a problem
for them which ultimately means it's
going to become a problem for markets
because that's the kind of the feedback
mechanism that the fed uses to drain
liquidity and ultimately demand out of
the system
what uh what questions you got joe
darius what's going on man appreciate
that uh that shout out at the beginning
uh
real good stuff my question would be
around that though like what do you
think people should do right i think
it's easy for us to sit here and say hey
start buying equities go invest in the
stock market make sure you can capture
some of this upside if this was to
happen again maybe go get a raise at
work but ultimately some of these things
are really hard to uh enact if you're in
a position where you're not able to do
this stuff what is your general advice
your general take on kind of what people
in this position should be doing
yeah so i'll start by saying i did this
i asked for raise and didn't get it and
left and bet on myself
um and that turned out to be the best
decision i've ever made in my entire
life
and so you you obviously need to be
financially empowered to make decisions
like that and so hopefully the folks
listening to your program are watching
and understand you know the central core
message you guys have been making um
this entire time as long as i've known
you guys to be doing this which is look
create yourself give yourself some
financial freedom and flexibility by
making thoughtful investment decisions
by saving money by allocating assets
appropriately and ultimately giving
yourself some financial freedom because
again the only solution to this as a as
a human being is again to walk into your
place of employment say i can you what
you're paying me is not keeping up with
the rate of inflation i know you've made
a [ __ ] ton of money in the last few
years it's time to share some of that
and if you don't if your boss says go go
af yourself then you leave and you walk
out of the door and you bet on yourself
and and i understand most people
listening to me don't listening to this
program now probably don't have the
means to do so so the second best thing
is start saving money you know i again
very much as a personal experience of
mine in the last years i would not have
been able to leave and start my own firm
if i didn't save money in the preceding
years in anticipation of potentially
having to make that pivot and so you
need to give yourself financial
flexibility which means you can't be
going to the damn gucci store every week
you know you can't be you know going out
to eat every every weekend you can't be
partying and picking up bar tabs and
stuff this is not the time you know in a
serious inflation episode to be sort of
you know cavalier about your spending
you know if anything you want to create
yourselves give yourself incremental
flexibility and start saving money in
case you do have to make that change and
ultimately i think a lot of folks will
and already have